mit mir im studio ist jetzt wie paul
ronzheimer mit einer exklusiven news bei
uns ja liebe anna wir haben soeben eine
neue entwicklung gibt bei flugzeugen bei
landung verkehrsminister scheuer will
durchsetzen dass keine flugzeuge mehr
aus risikogebieten in deutschland landen
dürfen das ist die debatte die seit
mehreren tagen gibt seit mehreren wochen
eigentlich gibt weil bis heute zb immer
noch flugzeug aus china und dem iran
hier in deutschland landen
der verkehrsminister nach unseren
informationen die wir gehört haben von
mehreren quellen ist es so dass es eine
schalte gab und minister scheuer jetzt
durchsetzen will
das ist diese landeverbote gibt
insbesondere wird das betreffende
flugzeuge aus china und dem iran beides
länder wo es sehr hohe infektionsraten
gab unklar ist noch was ist mit weiteren
risikogebieten also was italien angeht
aber ist es jetzt vor allem auch wichtig
die deutschen aus diesen ländern
zurückzuholen das heißt man will
offenbar bei rückflügen höchstmögliche
flexibilität walten lassen bedeutet zb
auch das nachtflugverbot angeht dass es
in einen erweiterten spielraum für für
ankommende flugzeuge gibt wichtig ist
noch zu sagen bei diesen verboten oder
bei diesem version versucht das jetzt zu
verbieten ist der minister auch auf die
länder und die jeweiligen kommunen
angewiesen
das heißt bei großen flughäfen wie
frankfurt münchen und so weiter wird
jetzt gesprochen da wird mit den
zuständigen gesundheitsämtern auch
darüber gesprochen wie man das ganze
jetzt durchsetzt aber fakt ist die
bundesregierung verkehrsminister scheuer
will ihr durchgreifen und klar machen
dass keine flugzeuge mehr aus
risikoländern in deutschland landen
dürfen also keine flugzeuge landen aus
iran aus china insbesondere was ja
wichtig ist klappt in iran ist ein
großer feiertag in vier tagen wo viele
traditionell auch reisen entweder leute
iraner von hier
in die heimat reisen oder umgekehrt
stellt sich natürlich die erste frage
warum hat das eigentlich so lange
gedauert also die lufthansa sehr schnell
ihre direkt in die nacht hinein gestellt
aber direktflüge aus china dürften immer
weiter hier landen
anna es ist glaube ich wie bei allen
maßnahmen über die wir in den
vergangenen wochen diskutiert haben
da gab es immer wieder argumente vor
allem wirtschaftliche argumente dass das
sozusagen die wirtschaft beeinträchtigen
könnte deswegen wollte man noch nicht so
radikal sagt man reagieren aber sehr
sehr großes thema eben auch was es mit
den deutschen die in diesen ländern sind
werden wir vergleichen mit anderen
ländern ist es so dass österreich diese
maßnahme schon vor mehreren tagen
angekündigt hat dort wurden
sondermaschinen eingesetzt auch um
österreicher aus italien zurück zu holen
aber wie ich gerade gesagt habe es ist
noch offen was mit italien passiert
möglicherweise gibt es dort auch
regionale unterschiede weil auch in
italien die ausbreitung des virus ja
unterschiedlich ist aber es ist möglich
dass es zum beispiel auch flugverbote
aus städten wie venedig oder anderen
gebieten geben könnte wo es ja eine
große zahl von virus fällen noch gibt
aber fakt ist in jedem fall flugverbot
momentan china und iran ich glaube das
hat natürlich auch mit politischen druck
zu tun der vergangenen tage denn niemand
hat mir wirklich verstanden was das
eigentlich soll ja warum dürfen diese
flugzeuge hier in deutschland noch
landen jetzt hat der verkehrsminister
durchgegriffen und will diese dinge
verändern und wissen wer dazu kann man
auch sagen wir haben ja schon vor sechs
wochen hat der handelsbeauftragter der
eu sich schon darüber beschwert dass er
der nach china zurück einreisen wollte
in china in quarantäne musste umgekehrt
als er aus china kam gab es keine
garantien und damals war es ja noch so
dass hier sehr wenig vereinzelte fälle
gab und ich eben in china die infektion
hochging mittlerweile ist es ja
umgekehrt
wir haben auch vor drei wochen armin
laschet gefragt warum das eigentlich so
ist und darauf hingewiesen dass es
reichlich absurd war damals aber noch
nicht wirklich angekommen zu sein nein
man hat das gefühl dass wir tatsächlich
täglich neu entschieden wird auch
aufgrund des drucks der druck der durch
andere länder geschieht und man muss
sagen dass
diese einzige maßnahme die es bislang
gab für zurückkommende aus diesen
ländern war ein formblatt wo man etwas
auffüllen musste und dann konnte man
durch durch die kontrolle dann war man
in deutschland also keine fieber
messgeräte keine weitergehende prüfung
obwohl es in anderen ländern anders ist
ich habe es ja erzählte venezuela
neulich und selbst da wurde viel war
gemessen bei herrn genau als ich in
caracas gelandet bin vor zwei wochen
wurde bei jedem einzelnen passagier
fieber gemessen und kontrolliert und in
deutschland reichte bislang ein
formblatt aber nun soll es anders sein
wie gesagt flugverbote sollen
durchgesetzt werden aus risikogebieten
unter anderem iran und china und wissen
wir denn ab wann das er in kraft tritt
es ist jetzt so dass auch da wieder
unsere föderale struktur natürlich eine
rolle spielt das entscheiden dann mit
die kommunen die länder die
gesundheitsämter in diesen in diesen
standorten in dem fall frankfurt und
münchen und da werden wir jetzt abwarten
müssen wann genau das der fall sein wird
wie gesagt wichtig ist für die
bundesregierung natürlich auch die frage
was passiert mit den deutschen die in
diesen ländern sind die muss man jetzt
zurückholen möglichst man muss man muss
sozusagen versuchen sie schnell
zurückzuführen aus diesen ländern um
dann sicherzustellen dass die deutschen
auch hier wieder nach hause kommen
können